[Musique]
à lire à b bonjour bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du café politique
installez-vous on va on va évoquer bien
sûr votre parcours personnel parcours
politique parcours politique qui est
déjà assez assez chargé malgré votre
jeune âge vous avez 33 ans aujourd'hui
porte parole
depuis peu du mouvement générations
mouvement lancé par benoît hamon vous
avez été pendant longtemps membre du ps
conseiller municipal à poissy à trappes
désormais président aussi des jeunes
socialistes des yvelines avant la liste
est assez longue je le disais pour 33
ans de caen vous date et concrètement
votre engagement politique qu'est ce qui
a fait que vous êtes lancer dans la
politique
moi j'ai toujours été intéressé par la
politique qui est la vie politique en
général je me rappelle mes premiers
souvenirs politiques répond remonte à
l'époque de mitterrand
je devais avoir une toute petite dizaine
d'années mais le mont vrai éveil à la
politique c'est le 21 avril 2002 avec la
qualification au second tour de jean
marie le pen face à jacques chirac l
élimination de la gauche à l'époque
le pays entier était bouleversé le monde
entier d'ailleurs puisque nous faisions
la une de tous les journaux à travers le
monde et les français s'étaient
massivement mobilisés
trois millions de manifestants un
million sur les champs elysées et moi
j'ai eu à ce moment là parce que je
n'avais pas le droit de vote
vous savez 17 ans et demi donc j'étais
encore que de très peu j'étais frustré
de ne pas pouvoir voter au second tour
contre l'extrême droite et donc j'ai
choisi de manifester
c'est mon premier acte militant en
quelque sorte même s'il ne se traduisait
pas par un engagement de plus long terme
dans un parti politique
votre première famille politique c'est
donc le parti socialiste pourquoi le
pour le parti socialiste à l'époque
et pourquoi pas le parti communiste ou
les le les radicaux de gauche par
exemple pratique de gauche j'ai jamais
vraiment songé je le reconnais il y
avait mon premier vote aux élections
régionales de 2002 2004 et est pour le
parti communiste
je me suis engagé un an après à peu près
au ps parce que je considérais que
consacré son énergie surtout quand on
est jeune homme consacrer son énergie à
changer utilement la vie des gens je
vous disais moi je suis issu d'une
famille modeste d'un quartier populaire
et je considère qu'il est plus utile de
s'engager dans un grand parti à vocation
majoritaire comme tel ps a des potes qui
étaient capables de synthétiser les
différentes traditions de la gauche pour
pouvoir essayer de changer au
concrètement la vie des gens et
d'accéder directement aux
responsabilités en intégrant 1
en prenant le pouvoir intégrer le
gouvernement le ps malheureusement à
dériver ces dix dernières années et
entre les raisons qui m'ont poussé à
m'engager à l'époque au parti socialiste
est les raisons qui m'ont poussé le
quitter et il s'est passé une décennie
notamment un quinquennat où la gauche a
été au pouvoir où elle a trahi les
engagements qu'elle a pris auprès de
ceux qu'elle prétend défendre
on va revenir sur ce sujet là
précisément on vous connu aussi
principalement en tout cas
médiatiquement aussi pour être un proche
de benoît hamon
aujourd'hui c'est votre mentor politique
l'on peut dire c'est c'est un modèle
pour vous alors c'est exagéré de dire
serge et je ne suis pas du tout si vous
parliez de françois mitterrand tout à
l'heure ça a été une figure forcément
importante de la gauche
est ce que pour vous mais nous avons
c'est un peu votre françois mitterrand
avoue ne pas faire de comparaison de
cette nature en tout cas
moi je ne crois pas aux hommes
providentiels ça tombe bien benoît hamon
non plus c'est aussi pour ça qu'on se
retrouve et je ne crois pas qu'un homme
seul a la responsabilité de soi servir
de mentor à une génération militante
soit transformé le destin d'un pays moi
j'ai quelques figures qui m'ont marqué
vous avez parlé de françois mitterrand
je confirme henri emmanuelli aussi vrai
que je me suis engagé dans mes plus
jeunes années militantes notamment on
avait défendu dans les comités qui
l'avait lancé du non socialiste 1 le non
au référendum constitutionnel de
européen en 2005
un nom qui a gagné d'ailleurs largement
grâce aux voix des socialistes qui sont
engagés pour le nom entre autres et qui
n'a pas été respecté d'ailleurs par le
parlement puisque quelques années après
le texte similaire a été voir des petits
mini à l'assemblée nationale vous avez
aussi suivi benoît hamon malgré votre
jeune âge on au ministère de l'éducation
nationale ça devait être une expérience
forcément enrichissante pour vous quels
souvenirs vous gardez de cette
expérience ministérielle est ce qu est
ce que c'est un endroit qui est qui qui
vous en garde un bon souvenir c'est
plaisant d'être dans les hautes sphères
de l'état ou alors finalement c'est
assez ça éloigne aussi du terrain et de
la vraie vie jury d'air je me suis
jamais éloigné de la vraie vie du
terrain puisque j'ai toujours été
militant local et élu local y compris
pendant mes années d'engagement
ministère d'abord de l'économie sociale
et solidaire et de la consommation et
quatre mois une star de l'éducation
nationale c'est une expérience
absolument irremplaçables
enthousiasmante
on a les responsabilités directement du
pays on est en mesure de mettre en
oeuvre des lois comme la loi qu'apporter
benoît hamon et son cabinet sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire une
autre loi sur la consommation c'est des
droits concrets pour les français c'est
la possibilité de reprendre son
entreprise sous forme de coopérative
avec des salariés
si le patron décide de mettre la clé
sous la porte ou de revendre ou de céder
son entreprise c'est la possibilité
d'acheter ses lunettes moins cher c'est
la protection des consommateurs c'est la
possibilité pour les consommateurs qui
se sentent floués par je sais pas -
l'opérateur de téléphonie de se mettre
ensemble pour pouvoir défendre par une
action de groupe leurs droits c'est des
choses très concrètes qu'on apporte je
vous le disais tout à l'heure dans mon
engagement aider directement ceux des
notamment les classes populaires dont je
suis issue qui souvent n'ont pas les
moyens de s'organiser quand on prend des
responsabilités quand on a la chance et
l'honneur de participer à une aventure
ministériel mais je remercie benoît
monde m'avoir offert cette opportunité
on essaye de capitaliser la plainte
d'être le plus utile à son pays
alors aujourd'hui vous l'avez suivi dans
son mouvement générations vous avez même
mis du temps à quitter le ps lui elle a
quitté avant vous pourquoi vous avez
attendu pour quitter le ps est ce que
vous pensiez à un changement après les
présidentielles et législatives
beaucoup de socialistes
beaucoup de ceux d'ailleurs qui ont
soutenu benoît hamon espérer un
changement mais je n'y croyais pas vous
avez une petite différence
je vous avais moi j'ai été j'étais à ses
côtés pendant la campagne présidentielle
où j'ai vécu en direct comme lui l'a
vécu mes plus il a vécu plus fortement
parce qu'il était le candidat je les
trahisons
la désertion organisé deux cadres du
parti socialiste parlementaire de
députés qui chaque jour deux ministres
et qui chaque jour annoncé leur départ
pour soutenir emmanuel macron je peux
comprendre que le réflexe de benoît
hamon la décision qu'il a prise au
lendemain de la présidentielle ce soit
de dire basta j'arrête avec tout ça il
aurait peut-être dû le faire avant
d'ailleurs peut-être beaucoup beaucoup
le pensent mais pas tort peut-être qu'il
aurait dû suivre d'ailleurs le conseil
de françois hollande pendant la
présidentielle et se sentir beaucoup
plus libre beaucoup plus libre de rompre
avec ce qui ne choisissaient pas de le
soutenir
sincèrement honnêtement complètement dès
le lendemain de sa victoire aux
élections primaires ça c'est un autre
débat
un autre débat qui mériterait une heure
de discussion mais en tout cas c'est
logique qu'il ait voulu prendre sa
liberté totale et défendre les
convictions qui sont les siennes dès le
lendemain de la présidentielle pour ma
part moi j'étais je suis militant engagé
au ps depuis je vous dis plus d'une
dizaine d'années et
je croyais que le parti avait les
ressources pour pouvoir se remettre en
cause et qu'une claque pareille aux
présidentielles et aux législatives
permettait y compris aux esprits les
plus réticents à la remise en cause de
s'interroger et finalement statué que
les mois qui ont fait la démonstration
que définitivement quelque chose est
pourri au sein du parti si vous avez
rejoint du coup génération avec une
centaine de cadres et de militants
socialistes des désirs line est ce que
vous dites aujourd'hui concrètement le
parti socialiste est mort et vive
génération l'avenir ces générations
bah je ne sais pas si le ps est
définitivement mort s'il se contentera
d'être comme certains d'ailleurs
l'imaginent un parti croupion d'une
majorité matrone east en tout cas moi je
n'ai pas ma place je ne me vois pas être
au sein d'un tout petit parti politique
il réduit finalement à peau de chagrin
génération aujourd'hui c'est plus
important que le parti vous avait pas
d'élu j'en suis convaincu on a cinquante
mille plus cinquante mille militants
déjà engagés dans 700 comité si je
prends la fédération des vignes c'est le
cas il ya beaucoup plus aujourd'hui de
militants au sein de génération je vous
disais une centaine de militants et de
cadres du ps qui ont décidé
collectivement de partir à génération
mais avant que nous n'arrivions en
génération y avait des centaines de
personnes engagées qui pour la plupart
d'entre eux n'ont jamais été dans un
parti politique il faut bien comprendre
que presque 70% des adhérentes
générations n'ont pas d'antériorité ni
au ps ni chez les écologistes ni au
parti communiste
et ça c'est une vraie ressemble à la
république en marche un petit peu mais
où il se dresse et de ce point de vue là
et à la france a soumises à certains
égards de ce point de vue là oui voilà
trois mouvements qui sont capables
d'attirer à la politique des gens qui en
sont éloignées l'objectif maintenant
c'est de s'ancrer politiquement
peut-être est-ce que
vous avez déjà des ambitions pour 2019
les élections européennes 2020 les
municipales qui semblent être les plus
importantes quand même pour un nouveau
mouvement déjà la prochaine échéance et
les européennes est un mouvement comme
le nôtre profondément européen très
critique vis-à-vis de l'orientation
libérale actuelle de l'union européenne
ne peut pas être absente de ce rendez
vous donc nous travaillons surtout par
l'élaboration d'une plateforme politique
au niveau européen avec des partenaires
européens c'est un peu l'originalité de
la démarche du mouvement générations
avec comme partenaire yannis varoufakis
et son mouvement dit m 25 ans regrettait
qu' ancien ministre des finances au
service des finances qui est venu qui
est très connu pour être fortement tenir
battu la politique d'austérité imposée
par la fameuse troïka en particulier par
l'allemagne qui n'a barrières ont cédé
wolfgang schauble mills et financeraient
tap le tortionnaire du peuple grec et il
ya une star oprah qui savait mener ce
combat là aux côtés du premier ministre
à l'époque il est créé son mouvement
politique
il a engagé avec benoît hamon une
démarche de coalition au niveau européen
de tous les mouvements politiques dans
leur diversité qui souhaite mettre fin à
l'austérité
notre combat c'est d'ancrer notre parti
notre pays dans la perspective
européenne mais c'est en même temps de
refuser que la seule logique est le seul
horizon possible pour les européens soit
un horizon l'austérité est libéral et du
coup quel rapport avec la france
insoumise parce que si vous semblez
avoir d'un point de vue national
beaucoup d'atomes crochus sur la
question européenne semble ne pas être
le cas comment vous allez faire parce
que si la gauche veut revenir au pouvoir
aux élections européennes aux
municipales d'anciens les échelons il
faudra s'allier forcément comment vous
allez appréhender cette question avec la
france un smith vous êtes favorable à
des alliances très rapidement nous on
est génétiquement j'ai envie de
dire pour l'union de la gauche et on
considère que c'est la diversité des
composantes au sein de la gauche qui
nous permettra demain de présenter un
front uni aux français c'est comme ça qu
historiquement la gauche a pris le
pouvoir le front populaire la gauche
unie en 1981 avec françois mitterrand la
gauche plurielle et emmenés en 1997 avec
la neige jospin et nous croyons que si
l'histoire n'a pas vocation toujours à
se répéter si la gauche est désunie si
elle montre ses différences plutôt que
ces convergences offrant cette gauche
alors il se désespère rond il ne se
rassembleront pas nous ne donnerons pas
la force nécessaire pour prendre le
pouvoir
donc nous nous battons pour l'unité de
la gauche il ya des différences
évidemment sur la question européenne je
l'avais table l'argent
où en est convaincu nous sommes tous
antilibéraux avec jean luc mélenchon
nous constatons que nous avons une
contestation commune de l'europe
libérale et austérité en revanche dire
le plan b c'est la sortie de l'europe ça
ne fait pas partie de notre discours
politique donc à une vraie différence là
qui devra être discutée et creuser ça ne
justifie de vraies discussions
approfondies avec le parti la france
insoumise maintenant je constate que
chez la france insoumise notamment
clémentine autain vient de s'exprimer
des voix s'élèvent pour dire que l'unité
de la gauche et un horizon qui doit être
l'objectif de la france 1 sont mises là
où son leader jean luc mélenchon semble
s'y refuse et je trouve que ce débat il
est sain et fécond j'espère demain que
la france insoumise adoptera une posture
plus constructive avec les autres forces
de gauche pour terminer cette émission
s'approche de la fin de cette émission
une question personnelle et certains
vous vous près des ambitions pour les
élections municipales 2020 attrape on
sait que trap est une ville particulière
il faut s'y préparer à l'avancé on est à
deux ans des élections est ce que vous y
songez clairement ce que c'est un chose
qui vous intéressent vous avez raison
trappe c'est une ville particulière moi
j'en suis tombé amoureux quand je me
suis investi à partir de 2011
j habite j'ai construit ma vie
maintenant moi j'ai jamais planifié dans
ma vie j'ai eu un parcours vous l'avez
évoqué assez riche mais j'ai jamais rien
programmé donc je vis au jour le jour
j'essaie d'être utile au quotidien même
pour l'amérique trapon mais quand on
travaille déjà au quotidien pour
améliorer le quotidien des trappistes
quoi qu'il arrive en 2020 je serai au
rendez-vous que voudront bien me fixer
les trappistes
mais pour ce qui concerne mon travail
quotidien je suis au service des
trappistes dans une équipe municipale
avec un maire qui la dirigent et
sommaire a beaucoup fait pour trappe il
a transformé tra pas uniquement sur le
plan urbain bien des égards et donc j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour ce qu'il a fait
et beaucoup d'attention a travaillé à
ses côtés à continuer de travailler pour
la ville de trappes merci à les rabais
d'avoir participé à ce café politique je
rappelle que vous êtes le nouveau porte
parole du mouvement générations adjoint
du coup aussi au maire attrape prochain
numéro du café politique vendredi soir
prochain à 20h30
[Musique]